Hey, everyone, we're here
for our last Wine Down...
-Whoo!
-PRENTICE PENNY: of the season.
Eight of these things,
can you believe it? Oh, my God.
I'm joined once again by Issa's
ride-or-die, Molly,
the actress Yvonne Orji.
-ISSA RAE: Whoo!
-Hello, guys.
This was an eventful season,
and we are so excited
to get into it.
This episode has Issa
going forth professionally,
and feeling comfortable
with her friends even
as she faces down 30.
-Y'all, Nathan came back.
-Where he been at?
-He ghosted.
-I dunno, V, you sent him away.
-So like, what was up with that?
-Yeah. 'Cause he's--
'Cause he had no right--
Girl, it's your 30th birthday.
Why you-- Why you like,
"Can we talk about this dude
like he's a real dude?"
Girl, it was your 30th!
And I was just lookin' out
for you.
When you're not calling
or texting for a whole month,
get outta here, no.
You don't care about me.
I don't care what's going on
in your life. Do better.
But it was rooted
in other things.
Like, Molly was bringing her own
baggage into Issa's thing.
-Lemme be real. Real--
-(LAUGHTER)
I just gave her a look like...
Real me appreciates
Molly's gesture.
-Okay.
-ISSA: But,
Issa was spun out
over this dude.
She's at a point
where she's like,
"I wanna make decisions
for myself,
and I wanna have clarity."
And it felt like Molly
was bringing her own issues--
But it was a bad decision,
like--
-What was a bad decision?
-YVONNE ORJI: Here's the thing.
I feel like Molly's like,
"Girl, you deserve the best."
Like, Molly thinks the world
of Issa, she thinks that like,
if we're gonna be adults,
we should be the same way like,
Dro was trash, like,
"Oh, you just gon' have a baby
with Candice?"
But you didn't even give him
a chance to explain.
It doesn't matter!
There's a whole child comin'.
I think Molly too, sometimes,
especially given what she said
in episode seven about like,
"Dudes are gonna say
whatever they--"
You don't need to hear
his explanation!
-PRENTICE: That's true.
-YVONNE: You don't have to hear
whatever he says,
'cause he's gonna say
whatever's gonna sound right,
to make a whole month
of disappearing sound amazing.
-Right.
-Or normal.
And girls fall for it
all the time,
and I think that's where Molly's
coming from.
-So, it reads as negative...
-I love...
-You go girl.
-Well no, I love that Molly
does not ride for Daniel,
she does not ride for Nathan,
but she fucks with Lawrence.
I think Molly's okay
with Lawrence not being
in the picture,
that's why she was like, "Oh!
We-- We good? How do we feel?"
But I think she's not okay
with Nathan being a replacement.
So, the one thing that we
always talked about in the room,
we wanted to say like Molly,
after three years,
like we wanted to kinda put
Molly into a relationship,
or at least a... like,
the blossoming of something
that could be like,
"Oh, could this work?"
And we went in the room a lot of
times about, should he be white?
Should he be this?
Should he be that?
What would this be if he
was Asian like,
like what does that do
for a character?
Kinda like, take her out
of her comfort zone.
'Cause I think with Molly,
we've always tried to like,
-challenge her way of thinking.
Right? Like...
-Yes.
Okay, if it's not a fairy tale,
is that okay? Okay, if it's not,
does it have to be this sort
of like, you know,
I'm in an open relationship
type of thing.
-Yeah.
-This idea of Andrew came up,
and we really were sort of like,
we really want to make sure
that we don't just make Molly
be this sort of tragic... woman
-Shakespearean flaw.
-who can't be in a relationship.
But that was a real thing for us
and we wanted to sort of like,
okay, but if it is gonna be
a guy who's not black,
-YVONNE: Mm-hmm.
-how do we explore that? And I--
In a way that hasn't been
explored before.
And I think Alexander,
the guy who plays Andrew,
he's great in so many ways.
-And I think Molly--
-Mm-hmm.
Molly's that chick who might
need somebody when she's like,
"Hey, yeah!" To be like,
"You need a hug?
Don't make me hug you."
-You know? Like, she's...
-Right.
She's that chick that like needs
the reverse of whatever
she's dishing.
The finale in a way,
just listening to it is like,
oh, there's a lot of people
getting answers, right?
Like, Andrew's kinda getting
some answers
about where Molly is,
Issa's getting some answers
about where Nathan is.
And even Lawrence is sorta
getting some answers
about where either Issa is
and his stuff with Condola, so,
I think it's really interesting
that everybody's sorta getting
a chance to like say,
"Here's what the situations are.
Now, what're you gonna do?"
This season, specifically,
'cause you brought up Lawrence,
has felt like,
very much a setup season.
Like, I'm not trying to say
like, we The Wire or some shit,
-but in The Wire-- We're not.
-(LAUGHTER)
-But in The Wire season two...
-But we might be The Wire.
...was just like,
"What is this?"
Like, what does--
What do these white people
have to do with these
black people on season one?
And I felt like this very much.
In season three, we've been
planting a lot of seeds...
-Mm-hmm.
-...to grow in season four,
with, you know,
Lawrence obviously, um,
considering Issa,
considering like,
given what happened with Chad
and him going back to the idea
of just like, should I?
Can I go back?
And then getting his answer,
"Mm-mm. I can't go back.
I'm gonna pursuit it
in this way."
And what that's gonna lead to
to season four.
And then obviously, Andrew
and Nathan living together,
-and Molly pursuing Andrew,
-PRENTICE: Yeah.
what that means for Issa
and Nathan,
and even Issa and Molly's
relationship.
So, it's very exciting to see
where we're gonna take things
-in the future.
-PRENTICE: For sure.
But what's fun about that is,
typically, we've always had,
you know, their relationships
is like,
"Okay, Issa's dating this guy,
Molly's dating this guy,
and like, never the twain
shall sort of meet.
But the interesting thing now
is like,
what will this friendship
be like?
And they've always shared stuff.
And what is this like
if Issa's like,
"Well, I don't wanna share what
me and Nathan are doing,
'cause I don't want Molly
to have a judgment,
and Molly if she's dating
Andrew.
-Like, you know?
-Like real life.
It'll be fun to see
this dynamic maybe plays out.
This sounds really messy, guys.
-Guys, that's what wrecks us up.
-That's what we're here for.
And then what if
one relationship
works out better than the other?
-Then who's at fault?
-That's the world.
-That's real life.
-ISSA: That's real.
-(GASPING)
-PRENTICE: That's real life.
-Y'all, we made it. Toast to...
-BOTH: Ay!
...the last episode
of the season!
Thank you guys all
for joining us
for our Wine Downs this season,
we loved making this season,
and hope you enjoyed this
as much as we did.
So, cheers!
-Cheers, y'all.
-I'ma be taking shots at home.
-YVONNE: Oh. Ooh.
-PRENTICE: Ooh.